et on débute ces insolites par la mise
en lumière d'un tiers-lieux qui propose
des formations en agroécologie son nom
c'est l'Ermitage et qui est engagé pour
l'humain et la terre l'Ermitage il ne
propose pas que des formations en
agroécologie je vous expliquais un peu
alors déjà il se trouve dans un lieu un
peu particulier c'est à dire dans
l'ancienne demeure de la marquise de
Pompadour c'est un parc d'un hectare et
demi qui est qui à la bordure du parc du
château oui oui et c'est Louis XV qui
donc avait offert ce cette demeure à la
marquise de Pompadour ça favorite
demeure bâti en 1746 voilà donc ce lieu
se tiers lieu existe depuis 24 ans et
c'est le siège social d'une d'un
mouvement international qui a été créé
par des laïcs chrétiens et qui s'appelle
fondation alors ceux qui veulent en
savoir plus peuvent aller voir leur
situation c'est en fait ce sont des gens
qui sont réunis pour vivre une sorte de
cohérence entre l'écologie la justice
sociale le développement personnel le
spirituel voilà ça m'a fait rire tout à
l'heure
là on est sur du vrai de la qualité et
donc les les rapports humains sont mis
en avant etc et on n'oublie pas la
nature donc fort de de ces points là ils
ont donc qui proposent des formations
soit sur le cheminement personnel le
développement spirituel des formations
aussi professionnel il propose
d'accueillir d'accueille des soins des
des sans-abris soit des sans-papiers
soit des des gens dans dans le besoin
d'être logé comme ça et hébergé il y a
une trentaine de places et il y a aussi
un comment dire un potager justement
c'est là où je voulais venir en venir
c'est un potager qui fait 200 mètres
carrés il y a aussi un poulailler un
compost un verger et ce fameux potager
200 m² en agroécologie alors est-ce que
je peux permettre sans douter tout ce
que je veux bah on a quand même un temps
imparti mais allez-y c'est pas pour vous
offenser mais je veux en vivre donner
deux petites définition donc
l'agroécologie c'est l'ensemble des
méthodes de production agricole
respectueuse dans l'environnement faut
un basta et la permaculture c'est un peu
la même chose si une approche globale
qui vise à concevoir réaliser maintenant
des systèmes économiquesment durables
socialement équitable et prenant exemple
sur les écosystèmes naturels dans quel
but mon Shark Grégory dans le but de
préserver la terre de préserver l'homme
de créer l'abondance et puis quand il y
en a trop bah il y en a pas trop
puisqu'on peut le redistrer au copains
voilà donc fort de ça ah tiens un tout
petit peu d'histoire encore allez en
1928 le terme agroécologie est arrivé
aux États-Unis avec Basile benssin bref
sûrement quelqu'un très
engagé là-dedans évidemment
et le japonais Massa nobuhaka il a
inspiré ce modèle l'agroécologie en
écrivant un livre qui s'appelle la
révolution
seul brin de paille en 1975 alors moi ça
me faisait penser à zelbrenpai à la
fameuse goutte d'eau du Colibri du
regretté Pierre Rabhi voilà ça c'est la
mise en lumière de l'Ermitage on est
dans quelle ville pardon on est dans
quelle ville on est à Versailles à
Versailles
j'ai un doute sur le fait qu'on est
précisé
ne soit pas trop loin donc il l'a Legé
près du bas ne fait pas mal d'ailleurs
on va on va enchaîner avec une piqûre de
rappel un photomaton on se fait tirer le
portrait dans un photomaton vous avez
pas fini
bon alors dans cette formation en
agroécologie Sandrine Barraine elle qui
est formée à ça qui a eu une passion
pour la nature le potager c'est formé
pendant trois ans elle a
exercé ses connaissances pour elle-même
elle a vu que ça marchait très bien et
elle est devenue formatrice et elle
label de formatrice justement très très
sérieux dont je ne retrouve pas le nom
ah oui caliopie label de qualité pour
les formateurs voilà elle vous propose
une journée 9h17h dans ce fameux potager
de l'Ermitage à Versailles vous allez
apprendre tout ce qu'il faut pour
démarrer vous-même un potager soit
permaculture ou agroécologique voilà et
vous aurez vraiment les bases vous serez
mis le pied à l'étrier ça coûte 145
euros qui a une formation par mois on
n'est pas plus de 12 et la prochaine et
21 avril voilà Sandrine Barraine est le
elle nous a envoyé des très belles
photos j'espère que vous avez
diffusé peut-être les remettre un coup
euh
bon alors le sol si jamais vous voulez
le sol n'est jamais labourer ni
retourner nourri avec en surface par des
déchets organiques et du compost voilà
la faune et la flore sont respectées et
l'environnement est ainsi très fertile
les plantes produisent énormément de
très bonne qualité pleine de bons
nutriments pour notre petite santé et
résistent encore mieux aux maladies et à
ses méchants ravageurs qui sont les
limaces les escargots et les Doris forts
en plus on économise de l'essence parce
qu'on la bourre pas et gnagnagna vous
avez envie que je termine non non c'est
très intéressant
piqûre de rappel sur sur le lieu puisque
vous vouliez faire aussi une autre
piqûre de rappel alors juste le
photomaton on est d'accord on se fait
tirer le portrait voilà ma transition on
va pouvoir la faire on est d'accord
alors là c'est exactement c'est un
photomaton un peu particulier ça se
passe ce 16 avril et c'est un photomaton
poésie
donc c'est la librairie la suite rue du
baillage à Versailles qui organise ça
c'est un photomaton bricolé en deux
personnes construit en deux parties vous
rentrez dedans c'est pour enfant ou
adulte c'est l'après-midi c'est gratuit
vous pouvez y aller vous choisissez une
émotion colère joie n'importe quoi et un
professeur de lettres aura sélectionné
des poèmes 19e 20e et trois comédiens
seront là cachés pour vous les lire avec
toutes les motion et et
le ton qu'il faut etc et voilà on vous
dit un poème pour vous vous repartez
avec
la poésie
de montrer qu'elle est accessible à tous
les âges et qu'il y a plein de poètes
formidables à découvrir
voilà
tout est dit merci Véronique merci
beaucoup on vous retrouve bien sûr la
semaine prochaine pour les insolites